hi my name is michaela peterson welcome
to my channel
this is a documentation of my 12 day
fast
which was difficult it was totally worth
it
if you want to find out more health
benefits of fasting you can check out my
podcast
above with dr jason fung and we go into
a lot more detail about the actual
benefits of
fasting i wouldn't recommend jumping
straight into a 12-day fast i would
start with intermittent fasting
but i did enjoy it even though it was
difficult
restraining yourself from eating for 12
days
for the sake of just curiosity
is difficult if you like the video
or if you want to see more like this hit
subscribe i hope you enjoy it
1.6 24 hours in
this is stable 79
131.2 so same as yesterday basically
and this is the back so
see what happens after seven days six
more days
2.5 and it is midnight day 2.
84 is still good
good night day two
so i woke up this is morning day three
and i'm literally feeling crunchy on the
inside
i don't know how else to describe it so
i'm down electrolytes
my wonderful husband is getting me some
toppo chico
with some electrolytes and i'm gonna
take that i don't feel bad i have like
buzzing energy everywhere but i'm like
dried up
my muscles need some salt
i'm using these guys which i will link
below
they have no ingredients other than
magnesium potassium
and sodium i'm coming out with my own to
rival them
eventually oh my god thank god for this
okay that's good so i had one
and i'm still feeling kind of crunchy
but slightly better
so we're having one more and that makes
2000 milligrams of sodium 400 milligrams
of potassium and 120 milligrams of
magnesium
okay that electrolyte pack hit the spot
and i'm feeling
amazing energy wise mood wise things are
good
andre where are you
he's not feeling as good
74 hours in
ketones at 3.3
131.6 taken i drank a lot of water
but as you can see my weight stays
amazingly stable
for not having eaten anything for three
days
andre brought me a topo chico and i'm
having more electrolytes
it is morning day four and i went to
sleep at 1 30. i woke up at 8
30 so that's seven hours i'm
not feeling ideal the larger lights will
make me feel better i'm feeling like
full of energy but i don't feel crunchy
today anyway
but not ideal
electrolytes will help
um have anything else to report
not really i slept okay i didn't wake up
but i'm feeling
like buzzed like my heart is beating now
in an unhappy like a go kill an antelope
type of way
okay that's good
so busy
oh that's good
i'm 88 hours into this fast and
honestly i'm kind of hungry i'm on
instagram scrolling through and my my
instagram is just
food it's just food and like people with
nice ass
that's it so i'm scrolling through
instagram and
this guy i'll post it up here
has just pictures of donuts and it's not
like bad donuts they're like health food
donuts they're keto donuts they don't
have any grains they're not any sugar
and i'm just sitting there reminiscing
about when i used to make keto donuts in
2016 before i evolved
to the carnivore diet and now i guess
not eating and
i just i just miss donuts so that's
where i'm at 88 hours into this fast um
i'm gonna go have some
sparkling water with salt yay but yep
that's where i'm at
118 hours and 39 minutes into my
week-long fast
i am feeling fantastic yesterday was a
bit of a blip
but i'm feeling great now i'm wearing
a lot of clothes normally i'm in a
bikini but i'm freezing
so that's something that happens if you
fast i always wondered
how did people live in such hot climates
without dying
because i run hot they probably just
didn't eat very often
because that gets rid of that
overheating problem but i am feeling
good i might even
go past seven days we will see
but i'm i'm honestly feeling really good
other than the fact that i'm cold
full of energy i'm really stable i'm
quite
positive music is sounding amazing
um food is smelling real good but
we'll see for now i'm happy to continue
this
cute hair right this is this is me not
on instagram
like instagram i get all dolled up and
things and this is what i
actually really look like because my
hair's dirty uh what was i gonna say oh
yeah i had a period of the day
where i was just scrolling through
instagram and
pausing on all the steak pictures so
that did happen i caught myself
it was i don't even know why i'm
following this barbecue restaurant and
it's just them slicing brisket and i was
like
yes and then i realized i was doing it
and got off of that but
i'm at that stage of fasting right now
five days in
5.1
68.
128.4
[Music]
day six i'm feeling amazing okay here
are the downsides we'll go over the
downsides let's be real here
yesterday my mouth tasted awful so
if you get into serious fat burning
which i am now
in ketone breath is gross
and it's not gross if you're like i'm
always in ketosis and my mouth tastes
fine but like
it tastes gross tastes kind of gross
right now um
body odor that started yesterday um
and i don't ever have that so those are
the two downsides
i felt a little crunchy when i woke up
again but i had
one thing of electrolytes instead of two
and i feel
so good i feel
so good i'm so relaxed i'm so calm
clarity of mind is great my sense of
smell is sharpened
i can see better music sounds good and
i'm just
relaxed i don't think i'm gonna stop
tomorrow i don't see the purpose of
putting these needless boundaries on
myself anymore
so i think i'm just going to keep it
going maybe i'll do 10 days
then i can say i beat dad's record which
i really want i just want that
it's not even for a purpose when he goes
yeah well i did a 10 day fast i
just want to be like yo well i did 11
days just so you can't say that anymore
but i feel really good
i've been working i've been working out
like i'm fine i'm on fire man
so we'll check ketones again tonight
and we'll see how tomorrow is but i got
over the
four day hump i felt i felt not great on
for the fourth day
and i might just keep this going
keep it going also totally channeling
garth right now
i feel like how garth feels except with
more
sharpness
i'm on fire this fast is epic
i'm never eating again that is how i
feel
i'm definitely going beyond seven days
i'm so productive my sense of smell is
sharpened can you sharpen a sense of
smell i feel like you can you can
get to a six day fast and you'll know
that you can sharpen a sense of smell
my eyesight is better my mood is stable
i feel so good i have accomplished so
much
i feel the whole breatharian thing
as if i needed to get more controversial
i may become a breatharian
so yeah i think i'm gonna stick it out
beyond seven plus then i can be like dad
remember that 10 day fast you did
11 days sucker just so i can say that
[Music]
i'm so tired um so i'm done my seven day
fast
i'm definitely i'm so exhausted
i worked out today which was fine
i launched a podcast a website and a
newsletter
i've done so much work in the last week
i've been so productive
and i cooked a bunch today which was a
little torturous
um but i think i'm gonna actually push
this to a 10 day fast
i'm really happy with how i feel i'm
really emotionally stable um
which i got people do get more
emotionally stable when they fast but it
makes me more
convinced that whatever my problem is
is gut related because i just feel so
much better like this so i think i'm
going to push it to 10 days
we'll see if my skin is super clear i'll
um
do a photo or a video without makeup
but i'm wearing lipstick because i can
go out for dinner watch everyone else
eat and just wear lipstick because i
don't eat any of it off
so i'm going to take my ketones again
take my weight
and go to bed because this is 12 o'clock
and i have a toddler
that i have to get up with and i've
totally exhausted myself today with work
before it's not too bad it's not super
high
pretty good glucose 81
[Music]
and 25.2
so this is my skin without any makeup a
little bit of
lanolin on from night time i sleep with
lanolin
um these marks are old
from the last time i drank alcohol which
was a few weeks ago and that always
breaks my skin out but my skin is
looking
really good from this fast which is
surprising because
most of the other fasts i've done my
skin breaks out
a little bit um and i told you i think
it's because
the fat that i'm burning right now is
cleaner i know how that might sound but
i still think that's what it is
i've also stayed pretty hydrated i've
been drinking about a
liter and a half of water a day with
four thousand milligrams of sodium
um just like 1200 milligrams of
potassium
and 320 milligrams of magnesium
and i've been doing that every day so i
feel good
um day four was definitely the roughest
this is the morning of day eight and
waking up this morning wasn't i didn't
feel as crunchy as
i did on day four so as dehydrated i
would say
i feel pretty good actually i feel
really good honestly
so i'm gonna have some electrolytes keep
going
but i feel good i definitely look better
than i did
um from the fat loss so i think what
i'll do is
10 days and then start with
broth pretty slowly for re-feeding
because
once you do extended fast at least when
i do them if you start eating
like a lot right off the bat you're it
just wreaks havoc on your digestion so
i'm probably going to re-feed in like
three days really slowly starting with
broth but
i'm feeling good keto coach up in the
house
whoa guys whoa who's right
i like that guy better but like this
isn't good
someone's wrong day
eight
nine to three man see what my weight is
a lot of water
so here's a mess
i had
broth today so today's day eight of the
fast
i didn't have any fat in it so i
probably had
i don't know 30 calories today
i'm going to assume that didn't
do much my ketones are still super high
so i'm going to continue
but i felt like i wanted some broth so i
had it
i was still feeling good i had
emotionally had a rough day so
i wanted some broth to cheer myself up
also my podcast was weird i had an
emotionally really rough day
for various reasons but my podcast hit
number seven overall in health
whoa it's not alternative health either
or fringe health it's overall in health
so that was awesome so i'm gonna keep it
up for
another i was gonna do 10 days but i
guess that's only two more days
maybe we'll do 11 days i don't know
we'll see we'll see how things go
we'll see i might have some broth
tomorrow too am i not
world's my oyster man i think part of
the reason my ketones went down
yesterday was because i did a lot of
exercise
so that could have been it anyway let's
see
what's happening
huh
weight loss stalled because my 10
calories of
broth are kicking in
so it's day 10 day 10 and i haven't
eaten anything
i had a cup of broth two days ago cup of
broth yesterday
nada today i'm honestly i might i might
do 14 days
who knows i'm definitely getting more
attractive
my face is way different whoa
whoa and i feel fine i think i probably
had
2 000 milligrams of sodium today some
potassium and magnesium i recorded two
podcasts no brain fog
so i don't know what to say apparently
i'm a human camel that that's actually
i think from now on when i travel i'm
just going to gain
15 pounds from overeating meat
and then like chill for two weeks while
i burn through my own body fat it turns
out we're camels people
and no one is talking about it nobody
knows
anyway that's where i'm at so we'll see
what my ketones are at
so this is keto mojo which i use
although i've also used keto coaches
ketone measure
i haven't really used anyone else's
it's hardcore i didn't even flinch
finger blood and broth two cups of broth
that's what i mean in the last 10 days
5.1 whoa
damn i'm on fire
194.4 day ten
to make things more exciting i'm taking
22 milligrams of aco tmt
one 10 day empty stomach so we'll see
how that goes
so i think what i'm going to do for my
fast this is day
12 and i've officially beaten my dad so
yay for that um realistically i could
probably go a few more days but
i might have a tiny bit to eat today to
start really slowly so
150 or 200 calories or something
um and slowly ramp it up i'm also i have
to
travel so
i don't know we'll see i might have a
tiny bit and maybe i'll continue after
that but
technically that would count as breaking
my fast according to me so
day 12. look how much
thinner my face is isn't this insane
this is a vast improvement probably keep
going really
this is a tiny little crunchy beef thing
well i wasn't the greatest way to end
the past i guess
i don't think i'm hungry maybe body just
has decided not to live on food that was
kind of overly salty and gross and i
have hand sanitizer on that i'm pretty
sure i licked
so
not ideal i'm probably gonna eat this
and have a cup of broth
and then i might continue but this
technically counts as breaking it fast
my ketones shouldn't fall very much
though but
it's not as good as i thought it was
going to be given the black gap and
eating for 12 days
beef crunchy things wow
12 days i beat my dad
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed my fasting video i'm
going to go over
a few of the most commonly asked
questions just as an extra
i asked people on instagram if they had
questions about fasting so
here we go i consumed about
4 000 milligrams of sodium a day
i use those electrolyte packets so i
also got about
2 800 milligrams of potassium
and 350 milligrams of magnesium
approximately per day
i would really not recommend dry
and i would really not recommend fasting
without electrolytes electrolytes make a
huge difference
um one of the questions here is
if i'm a poor ass [ __ ] can i use tap
water and salt
and the answer is yes entirely you
just put a teaspoon of salt in tap water
but i would recommend carbonated water
with salt because
tap water would taste like drinking the
ocean and it's repulsive
how do you get started was a huge
question and
i started with 18 hour fast worked my
way to 24
worked my way to 36 and then once you
hit 36 hours and you're comfortable with
that
doing more extended fasting is actually
a lot easier so take it i would take it
slow
and start with 18 and then 24 hours
before you jump into like a 12 day pass
um some people ask about the refeeding
process and you do have to be careful
when you start
eating again when you've done an
extended fast um
it can really destroy your digestion so
i would start
super slow with like half a cup of broth
or like an ounce of meat
and then wait like four hours then have
another ounce and then wait for four
hours
if you go straight into eating an entire
steak you're gonna have a bad time
are you going to be able to exercise
throughout the week i did exercise three
times
in the 12 day pass no four times so i
exercised every
you know a couple of days so yeah
exercising was fine
um if you have trouble sleeping while
you're fasting
really increase your electrolytes that
should help
but honestly the longer you
incorporate fasting into your lifestyle
the easier it gets so
i don't have a difficulty sleeping
really with extended fast anymore but
the first time i did a seven day fast
there were a couple nights where
it was like three or four hours of sleep
and there was nothing i could really do
about it
if you're experiencing muscle cramping
again
increase your salt intake what can you
drink while you're fasting it depends
what you qualify as fasting i think
having a cup of brown broth
a day still counts as fast
coffee a lot of people drink coffee and
help with that expression
salt water obviously you can have tea
i would count all that as still fasting
and the last question was how do you
deal with hunger pangs and
literally like grit and willpower for a
while it's just like
you just suffer for a while and drink
electrolytes it helps a lot if you're on
a ketogenic diet before you go into a
fast because then your body doesn't have
to
burn through its glycogen stores switch
over to ketosis
and go through that phase at around
between 18 to 36 hours so if you're
already in ketosis it's really helpful
for hunger pangs but a lot of it is just
like willpower
uh so if you have more questions they
might be answered in the podcast that i
linked earlier but i'll link it again
here
on the podcast with dr jason fung and i
hope you enjoyed this video and hit
subscribe if you'd like to see more